Speaker 1: So I mentioned this yesterday in
passing, but I want to talk about it a little
bit more because it is really a fascinating story.
We are now learning something that I knew. And if
you watch this show, you also knew about the
fundraising that was done in the aftermath of
the 2020 election by the Trump campaign and the
Republican Party, supposedly to fight for the true
results and to fund audits and to fund recounts
and all these different things. We all knew it
was a scam. And the last I checked in with you
about it, about 70 or $75 million had been donated
by just random people who many of whom don't
really have the money to be donating, although
some millionaires donated as well to Donald Trump.
And we knew that it was a scam. If you looked at
the fine print, you actually could see that in
some cases, $0.50 on every dollar or even more
were earmarked to pay off Trump campaign debt.
But it's way worse than that. One of the things we
learned from the committee hearings, the January
six Trump Riot Committee hearing on Monday,
was that the entire $250 million official
Trump Election Integrity Fund or whatever
they called it, it was a complete and
total grift scam used in many cases to pay
outrageous speaking fees and salaries to Trump's
friends and family. That's the bottom line. And
I know it's sort of like, well, of course,
I mean, look at what happened with Trump
University. Look at all the different scams that
Donald Trump has run. Of course, it was a scam,
but it wasn't obvious to the people
who needed to hear it the most,
the Trumpists. So let's dig into that a little
bit more. Zoe Lofgren. Congresswoman Zoe Lofgren,
a Democrat who's on the January six committee, she
was interviewed by Jake TAPPER. And they talked
about this. And they specifically talk about
Donald Trump, Jr's then girlfriend, I believe,
now fiancee, Kimberly GUILFOYLE. Check this out.
Speaker 3: You showed. People deceived, talking
about why they were there on January six.
Speaker 6: Well, people were conned by
the former president. They were conned into
believing that the election had been stolen
and that they should go to the Capitol as the
president asked them to. They were conned. I
think the average donation from those e mail
false email requests was something like $17.
These were people weren't rich people.
Right. They were conned by the president
was a big lie and was also a big rip off.
Speaker 2: And you say you were just asked,
I think, by Monte Raja if the committee has
found evidence that Trump and his family, quote,
personally benefited, personally benefited from
donations, and you said, yes, that's a serious
allegation. Do you have more details? Is that a.
Speaker 3: Crime?
Speaker 6: I don't know. You know, we're a
legislative committee, so that's that's for
somebody else to decide. But, for example,
we know that. GUILFOYLE was paid for the
introduction she gave at the speech. I mean, on
January six, she received compensation for that.
Speaker 2: But is that. Is that a crime?
Speaker 6: I'm not saying it's a crime,
but I think it's a grift.
Speaker 2: It's a grift because
you're telling Trump people, Trump supporters out
there in the hinterlands give us money to to to.
Speaker 6: To go to court to defend
this election, when, in fact.
Speaker 2: And then instead. Kim GUILFOYLE, who
is Donald Trump Jr's fiancee, gets paid money for.
Speaker 6: 60, $60,000 for two, two and
a half minutes. You had money going to
Mark Meadows Foundation and to another
foundation? Yep. The Trump supporters
who'd lost their jobs. So it wasn't what he said
to his donors. This is to defend the election.
It was an entirely different purpose.
Speaker 1: Okay, so you get the point
what a teacher makes in a year. Hopefully,
after having years of experience in education,
many teachers don't make this okay. Kimberly
GUILFOYLE, the fiancee of donald trump jr.
Makes for a two and a half minute speech on
the day january six paid for by paid for by
the people who mostly don't make $60,000 a
year. She gets it for two and a half minutes.
Imagine giving. In some cases, your
Social Security check to a billionaire
supposedly to fund lawyers who are trying
to sort out the election for us. And then it
actually goes $400 a second to his son's future
wife. Okay. And what's amazing is how they are
such transparent grifters, but people fall for
it anyway. Now, I know that some of you say
screw, screw, and yeah, to some degree. Okay. I
mean, they are a fool and their money are soon
parted. If you believe after Trump did all the
other scams, we're going to build a wall that
Mexico is going to pay for. But some of them fell
for that. Obviously, it wasn't going to happen.
We're going to replace Obamacare with
something beautiful. Never even got a proposal.
All the if they still fall for it, then they
deserve it. Sure, that's fine. And it's less about
the individual, but it is a reminder that these
are not people. The entire political constituency
of Trump are people he mostly hates. Trump as a
rich New York City guy, has spent most of his life
trying to stay isolated and insulated from the
very people who he cons out of money. And once
they're no longer useful, Trump throws them out
like. Like his dirty diapers, for lack of a better
term. And the criminality question is a different
one. Is it is it arguably fraudulent? Yes,
it's arguably fraudulent. But like Zoe Lofgren
says, they are a legislative committee. They are
not law enforcement. And that's going to have to
be looked at. Erin. Rupert had a really, really
good piece about this, actually, in which he
outlines some of the different payments that were
made. And we're going to link to that and you can
check that out. But absolutely outrageous stuff.